this video is sponsored by squarespace
hey there guys thanks for tuning in
today i'm doing something a little bit
different i'm making my first ever
response video this being a response to
the channel natural hypertrophy he made
a video claiming that functional
training doesn't exist and my name came
up i was actually very polite and kind
about my channel so this isn't an angry
video per se
however i did want to make this response
just because i see an awful lot of
videos along this topic saying that
functional training doesn't exist
functional training is a fad functional
training is going to get you injured and
obviously as the author of functional
training and beyond i personally don't
agree and i'd like to clear up what i
see as functional training and just
maybe remove a little bit of hate from
the whole concept of functional training
and help us all to get along a little
bit more smoothly so i think the issue
that a lot of people have first of all
with functional training is that the
very name is taken as an attack on other
people's training because if this is
functional training it kind of implies
that your training isn't functional
people tend to understandably get a
little bit offended by this especially
if they spend years and years dedicated
to their craft and so they make these
videos saying that basically functional
training is a load of nonsense and i
don't like it anyways so that's where i
think a lot of this is coming from but i
think it's a misunderstanding because
that's not what functional training is
saying so one of the arguments i'm going
to structure this video as a response to
natural hypertrophy just because that's
an easy way for me to tackle all of
these points yeah one of the big issues
that natural hypertrophy has with the
whole concept of functional training and
this goes for a lot of other videos i've
seen as well is that how can a movement
be functional when really every movement
has a function the classic example is
the bicep curl is very functional for a
bodybuilder because bodybuilders need
big biceps actually the bicep curl is
functional for a lot of other stuff mma
fighters can really benefit from bicep
curls they're helping with the choke
holds and things at the same time it's
useful for carrying stuff etc but i
digress the point is that every exercise
has a function even if that function is
just to look good which is a perfectly
fine thing to do so if every movement is
functional what's the point of doing a
functional exercise at the same time
every movement is going to make you
stronger every move is going to make you
a bit healthier so why muddy the water
by saying that some exercises are more
functional than others then it goes on
to say that things like crawling on the
ground are not actually particularly
functional anyways because when do we
ever need to crawl along the ground he
says the same thing about rope climbing
when do we ever need to climb a rope he
says that to be functional we just need
to train to be healthy because all we
really need to do on a daily basis is
sit in an office chair he says that
obviously military personnel or athletes
they can benefit from specific training
but the whole concept of functional
training as it applies to a broader
population is nonsense again i obviously
respectfully disagree so really
functional training comes from the world
of athletics and if you're going to
train someone for a specific sport you
want to give them exercises that benefit
them so take the bicep curl example you
don't give a bicep curl to a sprinter
because it's not really going to benefit
them all that much instead you give them
specific exercises things like the 80g
split squat things like the barbell hip
thrust maybe weighted jump squats all
these things are going to translate
better to sprinting and running and
that's functional training so functional
training follows the law of specificity
it means choosing exercises to help you
to achieve the functions that you want
for your daily life and in the case of a
athlete or a military personnel there's
specific things that they can benefit
from they should incorporate and often
this just means including metcon stuff
and we don't just call that golf
training or running training we call it
functional training it's just a useful
term to describe that kind of training
and there are tons of highly respected
functional coaches who want these guys
standing on one leg on boasting balls
you only make a big difference and if
you give a mma fighter a functional
strength coach or you give a hockey
player or anyone else they're going to
see impressive results so functional
training at least in that context is
certainly not pointless and it certainly
does exist i've seen it so i know
exactly the issue with bodybuilding or
power lifting and the reason that
someone might say that their exercise is
a functional tomb why are they being
left out well the whole point here is
that in those sports the training is the
same as the activity you don't call
bodybuilding training bodybuilding
training you just call it bodybuilding
and so you don't call it functional
training either same with powerlifting
you're not doing functional training for
powerlifting because that just is
powerlifting the training is the same as
the activity just like when someone
plays football you don't say well that's
functional training for football it's
just a matter of terminology and you
shouldn't really get too hung up on that
and see it as an attack it's just a
useful term to describe something that
doesn't really apply to bodybuilding and
powerlifting because that is you know
inherently functional because it is the
same thing that they're doing if you see
what i'm saying for me and for many
people like me
functional training can sometimes mean
just training for activities and
functions that you want that you don't
necessarily need but want because my job
doesn't have to be the thing that i
train for so if i want to run faster or
i want to be able to climb a rope or i
want to be able to climb up a wall just
because it's fun and i enjoy it then
that's functional training for me
because i want those functions so i'm
training for a function rather than for
aesthetics or rather for a particular
lift or just getting better at training
itself so once again this is just a
useful term to describe the thing i'm
doing and as i've made this channel as
it's grown i've started bumping into you
guys in the street you've sent me more
messages what i've learned is that
there's lots of people out there just
like me you don't need to be able to
sprint you don't need to be able to run
long distances necessarily but you just
want to be able to do it in my case it's
because i'm inspired by superheroes
that's very apparent for my channel and
from this office and from everything i
talk about and actually again that's
something i've seen in you guys an awful
lot but otherwise you might just be
inspired by your favorite sports hero so
you might just not want to be you know
confined to your desk job you don't want
that to be your whole identity and so
for many people functional training just
means doing that your job isn't your
only functional at least it certainly
shouldn't be if you're just training for
your job
at home and then doing your job that's
just a miserable existence and for me
i'd rather be training for awesome stuff
so that when i'm not working i can be
sprinting around fields and jumping and
doing parkour or martial arts or
whatever else i'm into at that given
moment i'm actually lucky enough that my
job has become that so it doesn't really
apply to me in the same way but for
loads of people
extracurricular function is still
function so it's still functional
training so again it's just a useful
term to describe that and again it's not
an attack on anybody or saying that your
exercises aren't functional it's just
because like i say there's already a
term for that and what we're doing is
training for a function because that's
our main goal
but i admit this is where their waters
can get a bit muddy because someone who
doesn't understand functional training
and you know the many different things
it can mean to different people might
think that yes they need to now crawl
and sprint and climb ropes so they have
those extra abilities whereas for the
average joe they just want to get fitter
and stronger they don't need this same
as i say that the average joe doesn't
need to be a really great power lifter
beyond a certain level of strength
they're golden likewise the average joe
probably doesn't need to be a
bodybuilder so for the average joe
functional training means something
different this is why i coined the term
super functional to describe what i like
to do because yeah i like to train for
things i don't need to be able to do
therefore it's not just functional it's
super functional another term you could
use for this would be extra functional
that's what i mean by super i don't mean
it's so functional it's amazing i mean
it's additional to your basic functions
super can also have that meaning
extra functional wasn't quite as
marketable i said i can't seem to trade
mark super functional so maybe extra
functional could work what do you guys
think it's a bit lame how does
functional training apply to the general
population and why are we seeing this
movement why do we encourage people to
do the same thing i hope there's a
delineation on my channel between the
stuff i do that you know is like batman
training just fun and awesome and then
there are the exercises that i say
everybody should do and i mean that i
think everyone can benefit from a deep
squat i think everyone can benefit from
hanging from doing mobility work etc and
the reason for this is just that we do
also benefit from getting a little bit
of training for our daily lives even if
the function doesn't directly relate to
what you're doing and this is where
specificity can be a little bit over
applied because if you are just sitting
in a desk if you're just doing a desk
job then you might be fine for the most
part just doing a bodybuilding routine
or powerlifting routine
but at some point as you get older if
you're sitting in a chair all day and
you're performing those movements all
day at the gym you might finally start
to get a little bit front heavy for
example and that your shoulders start to
close in get a bit of kyphosis this is
where something like a hang can be a
fantastic way to deal with that likewise
you might start to notice your hips
getting a little bit tight if you're
always in that seated position and this
can cause pain on the lower back it can
cause an anterior pelvic tilt you've got
that donald duck but it's just not a
good look and whilst you might say that
you don't need exercise to become better
at sitting you might need exercise to
prevent the deleterious effects of
continuous sitting and i say again this
becomes more of an issue as you get
older i love bodybuilding i started as a
bodybuilder as i got older i started to
realize that a i wouldn't have the level
of athleticism that i wanted just from
that kind of training although i was
very strong i could do things like
handstands just from bodybuilding
training but b and more importantly i
was starting to see things like knee
issues and lower back pain i constantly
put my back out and it was by
integrating more functional style
training that i started to combat this
if i'd allowed myself to continue going
down that road it would have built on
itself and i'd have ended up with worse
shoulders worse wrist worse knees and so
just by incorporating a few functional
exercises what we consider functional
exercises again it's just a useful term
into a bodybuilding training or
powerlifting training you could end up
preventing these things and feeling
better overall and another really
classic example is if you're a
powerlifter or bodybuilder and all you
do is add mass and size then you're
gonna eventually find that you start to
get out of breath climbing the stairs
and things and again this is something i
experienced when i was bulkier myself
and not doing any cardio and to me
that's not highly functional you might
be fine with that and that's cool and if
you can do a fantastic lift then i would
take nothing away from that amazing
achievement however for the average joe
again
incorporating some cardio is so
beneficial because it improves your
energy levels it can prevent heart
problems and helps you sleep helps you
to be less stressed throughout the day
helps you look better again if you're
interested in the aesthetics so there's
just all these reasons to incorporate
that as well likewise with mobility if
you can't bend over and touch the floor
you might not have issues with it now
but there's a high chance that's going
to lead to more and more tightness over
time and eventually that could cause
back pain and then you won't be able to
do the exercises that you love to do so
if you just take one of those programs
and then you add in some cardio some
mobility work etc maybe some of these
exercises a back bridge or something
like that maybe some barbell hip thrusts
then you're gonna see your performance
improve and that makes your training
more functional more functional for
everyday life beyond your chosen sport
and again this isn't an either or thing
you don't do functional training or you
don't do functional training you're just
incorporating a few more functional
exercises into the mixture and the thing
is a lot of people don't like doing lots
of mobility stretches at the end of
their workout so they don't have time on
top of their training and this is why a
lot of functional exercises incorporate
these things at once like a one-legged
romanian deadlift that might look funny
to someone who's used to doing big lifts
you might think it's silly but the
reason it's there is because you're
building your stability ability to
balance on one leg which can prevent
itself from falling as you get older can
improve your performance in sports at
the same time you're training the hip
hinge movement at the same time you're
strengthening the lower back you're
doing all these things at once and
therefore saving yourself some time
getting some more bang for your buck so
that's why we have a lot of these
exercises and they might not appear to
immediately benefit everyday life like
crawling for example but crawling is
great for your coordination it's great
for your core it's great for your
mobility etc and by doing this all
that's going to translate to your daily
life so you have a bit more energy so
you're less likely to get injuries and
to feel stiff and something else to
remember here is that youtube fitness
really skews our view of what fitness
and health and training is because for
you guys a lot of people who are just
very healthy and want to look bigger and
stronger yeah maybe you don't feel the
need for functional training yet but for
an awful lot of the population just
being able to do one pull-up or just
being able to not have back pain in the
morning or knee pain etc that is their
fitness goal you know and more people
are in that camp than in the camp of
being perfectly healthy and wanting to
get stronger and as you get older you
might find yourself getting to that
point as well and this is again why
functional training is highly beneficial
for those people
and the other thing is that whilst this
might mostly be hypothetical the truth
is that you also sometimes do actually
need some functional strength a good
example of this one i often give is if
you're moving home or helping someone
else to move home
you might not need to do that often but
when you do you'll be really glad that
you have that grip strength that core
strength the rotational strength and the
capacity the work capacity to keep going
today i first jogged two miles to the
van rental place that's after getting
very little sleep last night and i've
spent over two hours just carrying heavy
ass stuff into the back of this van
which i'm about to take to the tip into
my office into our storage unit so this
is where some functional strength and
some functional training has really come
in handy there are plenty of other
examples like this and some situations
you might not expect to find yourself in
many people just like to be prepared for
anything but for me it's also a kind of
a badge of honor that you can do this
kind of thing without needing help and i
always thought one of the motivations
for me getting strong was i never wanted
to be the butt of that sort of joke i
didn't want people to say you know who's
going to help us move house adam no i
don't think so i never wanted to be that
guy i do think that natural hypertrophy
perhaps conflated some different types
of training and maybe missed the point
in a few areas for example he says he
doesn't understand why functional
coaches think that the pull-up is the
single most functional movement out
there the single most functional lift
and i'm not sure we got this from
because i think if you ask the most
functional coaches they'd say something
like the deadlift would be more valuable
likewise with the crawl he says that he
doesn't know why this is part of
functional training actually i think i
am someone who's a bit responsible for
introducing crawling more into
functional training most people would
associate crawling far more with the
likes of video portal who is not a
functional coach he's a movement coach
he's a movement guru and movement
training is slightly different from
functional training i think it's
actually very good and useful as well
and i also like to practice that but
they are slightly different he then goes
on to say that the pull-up in particular
he doesn't see the function off because
you don't normally have to climb
something in your daily life and again
i'm saying that i train functions i
don't necessarily need and that's still
a form of functional training however i
take his point that if you're just
looking to get your basic functions down
patch then you don't necessarily need to
climb things and he says that you
wouldn't use the kind of arched back
technique that most people use when
they're performing a pull-up well again
if he had watched my channel a bit more
he would know that there's actually
multiple approaches to the pull-up and
that the one that would be recommended
for its function primarily would be the
tactical pull-up whereby you would hold
using your thumbs on top of the bar
you'd use a more concave hollow body
position and pull straight up and this
is advocated by the likes of pavel
satsulin a natural hypertrophy goes on
to say that what you should be doing if
you're really interested in climbing is
practice climbing like a child where you
go up on one one elbow and then the
other elbow on a wall and push yourself
up he calls it like a a bad muscle up
but again this is actually mistaken
because you know kids whilst they do
move particularly well surprisingly they
aren't the shining examples which would
always be following in my recent video i
spoke to liam ellis from parkour
journeys and he showed me how to perform
a climb up which is a much more
efficient way of getting up a wall and
this involves moving up on your hands
just like this much more like an actual
muscle up and the reason we do this is
because otherwise you're going to scuff
your elbows and it's much slower so
again there is logic to all this stuff
stuff that might look a little bit funny
from the outside if you read into it
more then you're going to get a better
idea and of course there are good
functional coaches and there are bad
functional coaches just like there are
good bodybuilders and bad bodybuilders i
think natural hypertrophy in particular
should know what it's like when a few
bad eggs spoil the you know the whole
fun for everybody because as a natural
bodybuilder i'm sure he doesn't love the
insinuation that bodybuilding is all
about steroids it's the only useful
thing that comes from bodybuilding and
you can get gh gut and things
bodybuilding has tons of highly valuable
applications things like drop sets which
i love and apply to my own training and
anyone i train very regularly um but
it's easy to look at a few bad eggs and
think that's bodybuilding just like a
few people standing on boasted balls
curling weights it's easiest to say
that's functional training whereas
actually the best functional coaches
they look into this stuff deeply and
that's partly what i find so fascinating
about it's why i enjoy it because i love
the nuances of human performance and if
we read more then we learn things like
perhaps a disc type of pull up isn't the
best kind of pull up and for natural
hypertrophy he clearly has a very
analytical mind very critical mind and
he's correctly assessed the value of the
pull-up and that's basically thinking
like a functional trainer
that said a regular pull-up is useful
just for building a balanced physique
because if you are using a more arched
position then you're actually building
something more akin to a horizontal row
because you're building all those back
muscles across the back rhomboids traps
etc and obviously you can't do lots of
pushing and not do lots of pulling
because otherwise you're going to end up
with that hunched over position again
and there are many scenarios in life
where you need to pull things national
high battery actually goes on to say
that we should practice opening a door
and as any of you guys know i constantly
refer to exercises that are similar to
pulling open a door such as the banded
rose and things like that i'm going to
take a side step away from that video
for a moment and respond to a general
critique that i see from many other
videos of functional training which is
that you don't need functional training
because just training pure strength is
going to give you all the other traits
and properties that you need that
strength is the the foundation of all
human performance this is something that
i greatly disagree with and i think if
there's one thing that most people
should do it should be mobility followed
probably by cardio because if you've got
the energy to do something then you're
not going to be able to do it the
argument for this goes that you know if
you're strong you're strong if you do
lots of venture press and you've got
some squat and deadlift then you can be
super strong and that's going to
translate to a better swing with of the
baseball bat and a better punch however
if you want to swing a batch then you
need the transverse plane you need to
twist the body
doing a bench press isn't going to
translate to that because you're not
using those muscles and if you don't
think that that's a thing then surely
you only need one exercise because
surely just doing squats it's going to
build your entire body it doesn't work
like that you do need some specificity
you do need to choose exercises that
somewhat mimic what you're going to be
doing and then the argument comes that
if you practice swinging a cable to
emulate swinging a bat you're actually
going to train yourself to not know how
to swing a bat properly because you're
going to be mixing up those motor neural
pathways this again is just it's
speculation there's zero evidence for it
i did deep dives into this interference
concept and there's nothing to imply
that that's the case there are plenty of
studies for example we don't jump the
same way as we squat but there are
studies showing definitively that
squatting will improve your jump because
your body is capable of taking context
into account and having more than one
movement pattern it's like learning to
hook isn't going to ruin your ability to
throw a straight punch and learning to
write the letter b isn't going to ruin
your ability to write the letter a she's
going to train similar properties that
you can apply on the fly if you want to
get really deep into this into the works
of the likes of nikolai bernstein then
we know that the body responds to the
environment the goal and every movement
is slightly different and we actually
have a very complicated complex process
that helps us to select the correct
movement pattern every movement's
slightly different so by practicing
variations of movement we actually
improve our performance we don't muddy
it some even go on to say that all you
need is strength if you want to improve
your cardio because the argument goes
that if you find it really easy to bench
press 150 kilograms then you can also
find it much easier to bench press 50
kilograms and therefore you can do more
repetitions of 50 kilograms than can a
endurance athlete well actually
endurance is also domain specific it
affects different areas differently so a
swimmer wouldn't necessarily have great
endurance as a fighter beyond this
you're tapping into different energy
systems it's just nonsense i'm afraid
take a power lifter and get them to run
a mouth and they won't do as well as an
endurance athlete that's just a common
sense likewise they're better forms of
explosive and ballistic training it's
just about applying the right thing to
the right thing i think everything has a
place yes i think being very strong is
extremely useful and it's something i'm
interested in personally but it doesn't
cover every aspect of human performance
otherwise you know no one would do
anything else and power lifters would
just be the best at every activity look
at gymnasts that's a form of training
that applies to many other areas not all
but many and they train with a much
wider variety of movements i actually
think the ultimate approach to fitness
across the board health applies to
everything is to combine lots of
different types of training this is
another critique of mr hypertrophy
because he said he thought that by doing
so you'd be average at everything and
great at nothing because you can't do a
program that's equally as effective at
building max strength as it is at
building fantastic cardio and yeah i
agree with that i also think it's much
better to be pretty good at everything
by which point you're already better
than 97 of people who don't trade at all
and to be terrible at nothing i'd much
prefer that than to be someone who's
really great at one thing and who's
awful at something else he goes on to
say that humans are specialists and i
actually
wholeheartedly disagree with this i
think the whole point of humans is that
we're we're generalists and that's
what's allowed us to get as far as we
have not only in the realm of training
and health and movement but also even in
terms of thinking where a more
generalist approach can help us to
connect the dots across different ideas
i think that's one of our great
strengths and i think our training
should reflect this but again that's my
approach to functional training and
yours may differ that's not the only
thing that functional training can mean
then there are some people to say you
don't need functional training because
just performing the activity itself is
the best way to get better at that
activity and that can be true it really
depends on the situation the start is
not always convenient or practical to
continuously practice your chosen sport
or activity you know footballers kind of
have a match three times a day surfers
can't go surfing all the time so they
might want to train their court outside
of that at the same time adding a bit of
resistance can be useful depending what
you're going for so for example if
you're a martial artist who wants to
throw great kicks and things to look
good i said even then you could probably
benefit from just doing some mobility
work and that's functional training or
if you want to go into mma then doing
some metabolic conditioning or a little
bit of extra strength for those holds
because you know try and hold someone
like that for a long time if all you've
done is practice on your own and
practice in the ring and you're going to
struggle practicing holding a band or
something like this makes a big
difference so again there is benefit to
adding just a little bit of functional
training to almost any activity it's
also worth mentioning that there are
plenty of studies showing that a bunch
of functional movements specifically can
also help to improve athletic
performance weighted jump squats will
improve your jump height barbell hip
thrust will improve your running speed
weighted sled pulls can improve your
running speed but it is nuanced here and
if you add too much weight you actually
slow down and this doesn't translate to
greater running speed so you need to use
about 30 percent of your body weight
this is another example of why just
lifting really heavy weights isn't
enough why just powerlifting isn't
enough and some of those critics of
functional training will tell you that
you don't need functional training you
don't need explosive training because
you can't change your fast twitch muscle
fiber proportions all that much so you
might as well just build your max
strength and have more of a pool to dip
into this once again is just i don't
know where it comes from the studies
show that you have about 50 percent
pliability when it comes to your twitch
fiber makeup so you can change your
density of faster fibers by about 50
this also varies from muscle group to
muscle group but explosiveness isn't
just about fast twitch fiber anyways
it's also about things like neural drive
for instance the myotatic stretch
response which can be trained with shock
training and plyometric training so
again there's plenty of reason to not
just to power lift likewise powerlifting
isn't going to get you into a
bodybuilder's physique a lot of people
mistakenly start powerlifting because
they want to get a really ripped and
bulky physique and they just start doing
the three big lifts and this is the
recommendation of a lot of coaches and
whilst this will pack on muscle and
it'll increase your overall size it's
not gonna get you the kind of definition
and bulky muscles that you'd get from
bodybuilding there's a reason that
bodybuilding exists powerlifting is
great i think it's a fantastic way to
build a lot of strength it can improve
your mobility even it's great for bone
density has so many great traits but it
doesn't do everything and i think that's
one of the issues here people get so
wed to their single training style that
they want to convince themselves that it
does absolutely everything that it
possibly could and another myth that
surrounds this kind of thing is the idea
that you can boost your testosterone by
doing squats and deadlifts and that this
is going to result in greater muscle
mass that boost in testosterone is a
very temporary spike it doesn't stick
around long enough to increase your
muscle mass just like you get a boost in
testosterone from playing an action game
or having sex and these things aren't
going to turn you into a bodybuilder and
compound lifts might boost testosterone
very short periods of time do you get
the same effect from doing a full body
routine anyways for anyone who is
interested in building a lot of size i
would highly recommend a more
bodybuilding style program
turning to natural her perch fees video
for a moment i do want to address
another point he made that i personally
i'm not really following because i don't
think many people hold this view but
correct me if i'm wrong he says that
functional trainers and people who like
functional training all they really want
is aesthetics and they're lying to
themselves they're ashamed of being
bodybuilders and therefore they say that
they're functional athletes well first
of all i don't think functional training
has a better um reputation than
bodybuilding unfortunately as you've
demonstrated here a lot of people hate
functional training in fact i was kind
of reluctant to use that term in my own
marketing in my own site it's not all i
do by the way i consider myself a cross
trainer functional training is one
aspect of what i'm interested in you
guys know i also train my brain and all
sorts of things like that but the point
is that functional training isn't
something you're gonna wanna say you do
if you wanna avoid funny looks and trust
me doing something like a nordic curl in
the gym or even trying to find a space
to do a handstand against the wall
that's not a great way to avoid you know
the stairs of people who think you're a
weirdo functional training is is tricky
and the idea that all we want is
aesthetics is again i think misguided i
think it's very easy to think about what
you want and then assume that that's
what everyone else wants as well he
makes the point that i think you know
obviously has some merit that if i had
stick thin arms and a potbelly nobody
would watch my channel i take the point
that most functional coaches who rise to
prominence on youtube do have some kind
of good physique but this is a because
functional training does improve your
physique i made a video on um functional
aesthetics and why functional training
bodybuilding actually go very nicely
together because functional training
focuses on areas that even bodybuilders
sometimes miss such as the obliques
which can help to build you know really
nice well-rounded physique as well as
using metcon to melt away some fat the
other reason of course is marketing and
youtube algorithms yes people are
impressed by the looks but that's not
all they're impressed with and an
example of this is my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.8
which you should check out in the
description down below by the way that
has been selling really well beyond all
hopes and expectations as did the last
one and the reason is not because of my
physique if you watch the trader that
grant made that drives most of the sales
there's a small clip of me doing a
double bicep pose right at the end it
lasts for less than a second that's it
what i'm mainly doing is rolls and i'm
swinging a club bell and a kettlebell
and i'm jumping and sprinting and this
is just very dynamic it's action-packed
it's much easier for me to market and
it's those movements that people are
watching and saying that's cool and i
can honestly say myself that i'm more
interested in those kinds of cool moves
than i am in you know bodybuilding and
just looking good obviously i like
looking good and i like people to see me
and know that i train and i enjoy the
comments that i sometimes get i used to
get more when i was bigger however i'm
much more impressed when someone can
backflip or can do a plan i'm actually
doing functional training for my channel
i have to maintain a certain level of
size and definition to maintain my
channel and i combine this with the
training that is specific to those moves
so i can help sell books as a form of
functional training there are actually
plenty of functional coaches and
calisthenics athletes out there who
aren't super ripped and bulky and they
still get a lot of viewers i won't name
them because that's going to seem like
i'm dissing their physiques but i'm sure
if you guys think you can think of some
that maybe aren't classically ripped and
shredded but they do still have big
numbers also guys i'm married i have
kids i'm very happy i'm not out to pull
so i'm certainly not interested in
building a big physique in order to
impress the ladies in fact funny story
my wife before she met me and we started
dating said that she didn't like bulky
men just into thinner guys so there you
go it didn't help me at all in that
regard aesthetics is great obviously i'd
like to look more ripped but it
certainly isn't a priority of mine or i
train very differently and it's not a
priority of a large majority of people
those people who write to problems on
youtube who look particularly ripped
obviously there's a selection bias going
on there and there is the fact that it's
their job to do fitness they're all
going to look pretty strong and i know
you said you don't like it when people
say i didn't try hard i did try really
hard actually but i also do have really
good genetics so i'm not going to lie
because i think that's disingenuous to
my audience it's relatively easy for me
to put on mass and keep it on
so guys i probably had more points to
say i'll link to the article that's
gonna go with this video in the
description down below but i think the
main takeaway points are this functional
training is not an attack on other forms
of training it's just a useful label to
describe things that we know yeah the
term can be a bit misapplied it can be a
bit vague but when i say functional
training you guys basically know what
i'm talking about and the same goes for
anyone else and this is just a useful
term just like bodybuilding's useful
term and powerlifting is a useful term
to describe certain types of exercise it
describes exercising for a function and
that function very often is to do with
your professional sport and that's where
functional training really comes into
its own however it can also just mean
functional training for your life and
that means doing a light mobility work
and a little bit of strength in some
areas that might get overlooked to
prevent deterioration or to help rehab
it can also mean functional training
that goes beyond that because we're
allowed to have any function we want and
a lot of people do enjoy just climbing
stuff and jumping stuff and hitting
stuff and i think that was one of
natural hypertrophies gripes he said
that a lot of functional coaches i think
you know sound a bit high and mighty why
can't they just admit they just want to
do this for fun well i always on this
channel admit i'm just doing a lot of
this stuff for fun i want to be like
batman it's not a noble aim it's just
the nerdy bit of fun and i personally
enjoy it so much i don't understand why
more people don't also want to move and
run and sprint and jump but some people
don't just like some people aren't
necessarily interested in aesthetics or
numbers on their lifts they're all
different and that's great and we can
all learn from each other to me
functional training often means
incorporating different styles of
training in order to get a more rounded
type of performance if you're a
bodybuilder or a powerlifter and you
have poor mobility or poor cardio then
adding a couple of functional exercises
could help fix that don't have to but
it's something to consider there's a
distinction between calisthenics and
movement training and functional
training which is a bit nuanced the
whole thing's a bit nuanced and
functional training is necessary due to
the law of specificity if you want to
perform better in a particular activity
then you do need to do some exercises
that specifically target those things
functional training means different
things to different people but i think
we all know there is a general consensus
as to what it means and i think it's a
really useful and valuable approach that
i'm not going to stop talking about
anytime soon so thanks a lot for
watching this one guys i hope you found
it useful and interesting maybe learn
something let me know in the comments
down below if you agree with me what
does functional training mean to you and
again no hard feelings natural
hypertrophy this video is very well made
agreed with a lot of his points and i
value these kind of discussions leave a
like share this video around that helps
me out immensely subscribe to the
channel if you want more like this and
hit the bell button for notifications
that helps me even more and if you want
to learn more about what functional
training means and start applying some
functional training concepts to your own
training then check out my ebook
training program and over two hours of
video tutorial by going to the link in
the description down below for my super
functional training 2.0 either way guys
thank you so much for watching this one
and bye for now
and now a little bit about our sponsor
squarespace so squarespace is a platform
for building websites that makes it
extremely easy and intuitive and ensures
that anyone can do it this kind of
technology is exciting to me because it
levels the playing field it means that
anyone can set up a business online and
start earning money get their message
out there raise awareness or whatever
else it is that they want to do and
squarespace makes it easy to make
attractive modern and yes functional
websites thanks to its myriad of tools
so it has blogging tools for creating
content categorizing posts and
scheduling publishing it has member
management with email communications and
analytics it has inbuilt e-commerce
which is a great way of generating some
revenue and you can extend this further
with third-party plug-ins and extensions
which allow for things like management
of global shipping sales tax
reconciliation etc has social media
integration so you can integrate your
social media with your website and push
content directly to your site easy way
to keep the content coming and plenty
plenty more head to squarespace.com to
find out more and for a free trial and
then when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
link in the description for 10 off your
first website or domain once again thank
you so much to squarespace and thank you
to you guys for sticking around to the
end of the video it helps me out
immensely and as a reward you get to
hear me say bye for now twice bye for
now